Jade on the fantasy football chamber
great way before you get to New Year's
this is so great
so the fantasy football league you know
that Michael Rapaport was in the fantasy
football league yes he won like the
entire season and then the playoffs
occurred and he was kind of a shoo-in to
win and somehow JD beat him how did you
beat him I just I scored a little bit
more well actually his player he had one
player get taken out with an injury
before the game ended and that's how I
won the league and how much money do you
win I won $1,200 not very nice
so when you this is so weird so
Rappaport loses yes and Rappaport makes
it like you're calling him every minute
to gloat you didn't even call him no he
called me after his tape player got
taken out and I me and my wife have a
drink he knows Christmas Eve so we were
just laughing and she loves right before
she loses those podcasts all time she
was laughing at him and you know
whatever and you're ready good morning
yes these voicemails occurred the next
month are you long all right listen to
this Robin all right mm JD this is
Michael Rapaport calling you on
Christmas um I'm not here to
congratulate you for winning um Howard
should know that people are going to be
investigating this league in the
collusion with that [ __ ] elephant
Jason I also don't appreciate you
inciting green to scary on Twitter um he
never tweets yet he's tweeted me um in
my time of loss while I'm trying to you
know deal with with with the public
humiliation of losing you so um thanks
for that also also on Christmas so I
don't know what to say I lost it's
[ __ ] up don't call me again
okay it's the holidays I don't want to
block your number I don't like doing
that but I'll [ __ ] block your number
don't call me again
at all what do you mean don't call him
again just don't talk to him I don't
know he's a maniac he's trying to turn
it around on me to make me look like a
bad guy yeah so then he lost another one
huh I want you to know that my [ __ ]
feelings have shifted from sadness and
shame to anger jay-z okay don't you
[ __ ] call me up again and your wife
people call their wives their better
halves the fact that you got your wife
involved to antagonize me [ __ ] up also
okay so who's the better half who who's
the grown up in the situation JD and and
and and and and and you got Gary
involved too that [ __ ] big tooth
eight monkey
garbage or smell bad breath babbling
animal handle now I'm angry this is
after a yoga class you you [ __ ]
animal call me again and he snips a lot
yeah not man that guy all the time wow I
think he left another 180 tries to shake
your hand when he comes in here get the
[ __ ] away from me he's asking who's the
adult in your relationship he's making
all these [ __ ] oh why did you what
did your wife say about she was just
laughing at him and saying you know lost
you lost you know and he feels you and
Gary what did you do did you I just
tweeted congratulations to JD
condolences to rap before it's so close
and was it a real heartbreaker three
points oh and they and they both scored
over a hundred eighty cheese and JD's
points came I think towards the end
right yeah yeah so it looks like
watching JD score get higher and higher
and higher Danny just weeks passed oh I
was watching it going crazy going yes
JD's gonna win this yeah
what is this take Michael Rapaport Fox
Sports hose brings up Rapoport losing in
the stern he was a guest on the show on
Fox Sports 1 and a guy no no I said
Patriots Saints if you had to take your
power these are basically your Power
Rankings and I just want to say Power
Rankings in general and my fantasy
football league I wasn't even in the
Power Rankings yet I'm a champion
nothing to do with why we're here right
again oh I won this i won the other day
Howard Stern won
you have to bring that I lost that Lee
how many leagues are you in I mean to my
friend but I just I knew you were in
that league that was a very powerful
league it was a very painful loss ok and
I want to have my privacy about ok good
so the other legal one go ahead and go
humblebrag what is it you lost your
train of thought
when did he become an expert on fantasy
football and how he's a big talker it's
when he started playing with us it was
really a became I talked about a lot
that ended up on the Sirius XM's
fantasy sports show yeah but in the
beginning he didn't even do it right it
was his son he seems to know nothing
about playing for him you shouldn't shut
your mouth well laughs now he's become a
maven don't believe is he son was he
claiming that he once a motherly won
another league last year Sal and I beat
him in the championship and we barely
know [ __ ]